après avoir été équipé ses enfants de
l'association maurepas entraide partent
à la recherche de détritus dans le
quartier les friches une opération de
propreté à l'initiative du bailleur
social toi et joie on a pas mal de
déchet notamment parfois des jets par là
par les fenêtres et donc cette action
permet de sensibiliser les enfants qui
dès le plus jeune âge peuvent peuvent
avoir les bonnes manières et notamment
éviter de jeter un papier de bonbon par
terre et plutôt allait le mettre à la
poubelle
[Musique]
on a trouvé des caennais on a trouvé
deux on a trouvé dans un marché où on la
trouve plein de choses plus insolites
ces deux chatons abandonnés découvert
lors de cette opération de nettoyage
ils ont rapidement trouvé des
propriétaires grâce à carolina gardienne
dans le quartier depuis une quinzaine
d'années elle fait en sorte que ce lieu
de vie soit le plus agréable possible
on a fait construire des nouveaux locaux
poubelles encombrants et om ordures
ménagères pour éviter les bacs qui était
devant et que ça donnait accès à tout le
monde en passant sur la route qu'on
pouvait tout d'échéance à tous déposés
chez nous bilan de cette première
opération à des sacs bien remplis de
déchets en tous genres et des enfants
sensibilisés
c'est qu'il faut pas polluer la terre on
va polluer la terre